yeah anyway yeah i don't get caught up
in definitional games too much i wanted
to get into a specific topic
um which is you recently wrote a
discourse about hard work uh which i
thought was really really interesting
um and uh you know i have a bunch of
views and hard work uh maybe i'll start
off at a very high level like i think
hard work is important but i think hard
work is an effect of something that you
know needs to be done like if you need
to do hard work to get something done
that you care about then you work hard
but a lot of what i see going on these
days is hard work for its own sake
and i think we live in a very different
era than one that we evolved in we live
in an era of almost infinite leverage
and that means like when you are working
your decisions mean they echo larger so
there's code working for you there's
people working for you there's money
that's working for you so there's
there's machines working for you it
isn't just that you're standing there
with your bare hands and tearing at
something your tools were tool uh
bearing the creatures and so because of
all these tools available our judgment
matters much more than hard work so even
though i think sometimes you do need to
work hard and you should never shy away
from it if that's what it takes to
succeed in whatever you want
i do think that it gets overplayed in
society so that's kind of my view on
hard work but i think it's probably
a little more conventional than yours so
i just wanted to explore it together
with you a little bit how do you think
about hartford
i think hard work is yet another example
of a prescription to be honest with you
i think is done largely out of anxiety i
think hard work is done largely out of
fear
i think one of the common things that
you will
often hear in the world of sports and
business is that if if you're not
working hard and the next guy is and if
you're only putting in four hours he's
putting in 12. and so hard work has
become its own game it's like meditation
meditation becomes a competition so the
thing that you were really seeking
actually becomes replaced by
the game of hard work and hard work like
effort becomes sort of its own goal
and when and that seems to be the
pattern behind things is when you follow
a prescription or an intermediary then
that intermediary tends to replace the
ultimate goal and that becomes your new
game so hard work
it isn't you know the person who needs
to work hard
will work hard but it isn't that he
needs to be told to work hard and he
needs to
strive towards working hard i think hard
work is the result of something i think
whatever needs to be done when a person
has a sufficient and requisite degree of
desire he will do and from the outside
that will come off and reflect his hard
work to those who are looking but
but it isn't the opposite it isn't that
it isn't that if i work hard then i will
get this because then that introduces
what i call a gap and that gap is that i
must introduce some step in the middle
that i am being promised that if i if i
fulfill that step that some powers that
be or some
some force out of the universe will
grant me what i want because i have
satisfied that step
and i think that's that is the default i
think that is the
the way that everyone looks at things
and is being taught to look at things um
many things are named and and in the
naming problems exist and problems arise
so if someone wants to become the you
know arrive at the top of their field
you know
does that mean that they don't work hard
no but they would never view it as
working hard they would view it as i
will do whatever needs to be done to get
there and i don't consider that
work necessarily yeah consider that
the necessities you know you look at the
experts and to them what may look like
hard work from the outside to them is
play from the inside that's right in
fact one of the things i really think
people should focus much more on is
figuring out what feels like play to
them but looks like work to others
that's right because that's your
superpower and that's where you'll just
outperform everybody
you know i see with startups all the
time i see
lots of people who work really hard but
still fail uh and
often you know the most common reason is
they just pick the wrong thing to do
the world is a big place it's very hard
to figure out what's going to work
before it works uh product market fit
this thing that gets thrown around uh
coined by mark andreessen
uh it's a is a very difficult thing to
achieve so you're trying to predict what
the market wants you're trying to build
a product exactly for the market and
sometimes hard work alone won't get you
there i think what you choose to work on
and who you choose to work with
and actually kind of how badly you want
it which is more than just working hard
or more important than just the raw
hours you put in there are lots of
people running restaurants and uh you
know kind of meat space businesses not
in the startup world who outwork startup
entrepreneurs
but yet they don't succeed or if they do
succeed if they're much lower numbers or
much lower magnitudes
right and i i and i would say that
a large a large reason for that is
that society has been has been uh sold
romantic ideas romanticism is a very big
part of things
society very much seems to value effort
effort is a big deal and effort is um
sort of a
a
sort of an arrival of sorts uh for for
society that look how hard i work look
how much effort i'm putting in and
therefore i'm doing i am doing the right
thing by by doing that and and the
problem that arises from that oftentimes
is those who are very efficient are
demonized because very often you will
find in every domain those who don't
work nearly as quote hard as everybody
else but they get 10 times the results
and they're considered to be lucky and
so i think i think if you look at
i like to pattern things around nature
and if you look at nature
it doesn't work hard
if you look at gravity it doesn't work
hard
if you look at a tree and a leaf falling
off of a tree it doesn't work hard if
you look at a water going down a river
it doesn't work hard
so
everything
everything moves according to its own
rhythm
and whatever necessities are there
they're there and therefore they need to
be worked around but working hard is an
added extra romantic step in order to
put another feather in the cap which
says i succeeded by working hard
yeah it's also i think there's a
sometimes i i also think of work
as a set of things that you have to do
that you don't want to do
uh if you want to do it it's not work uh
so example is like you know you might be
grinding at work for 10 hours and it's
it's suffering it's painful and then you
get home and to relax you play video
games but to an alien watching from the
outside playing a video game is more
intense than whatever you're doing at
work you're running around with a gun
shooting at people you're jumping over
collecting mushrooms gold coins whatever
it is
that could be construed as hard work but
because you want to do it
uh because you can lose yourself in it
there's not suffering so i don't think
it's people get burned out on work they
just get burned out of work they don't
want to do which is a form of suffering
so
not and every thing that you need to do
not every step of it is going to be
pleasant of course uh but it's really
important to align yourself and work
where you're not suffering so when i
find like engineers who are out trying
to be sales people or sales people who
are out trying to be engineers it's
better to team up with someone who
really enjoys the other side of it uh
and stick to what you're good at um and
you know team up so that that's that's
why i think founding teams are very
powerful where you have one person who
can build and one person who can sell uh
because then neither one feels like
they're doing hard work each one is
doing what they enjoy uh but together
the company from the outside looks like
it's working really hard and as we know
in a billion dollar company the
employees aren't working any harder than
the million dollar company they're just
doing the right thing
and the right people are doing the right
things in the right way
and and
i think one of perhaps
the the
the key element of hard work which i
must say is an elephant in the room
which
is rarely discussed in the world is that
hard work is considered to be a door
prize it seems to be sort of the
preparing of the bed of failure
i think that a lot of times hard work is
done in order to have an excuse for the
mind when the mind comes attacking and
says how come you didn't make it
and if a person is armed
with the ammunition that i have worked
hard then he has an answer for the mind
whereas if he just had on the couch and
did nothing
he would not have that ammunition so
many times people do hard work
in order to have an answer for the mind
because they know they're going to fail
anyways
and externally if i'm an investor in a
company it fails the entrepreneur worked
hard that feels more forgivable socially
than someone who's just like oh i tried
it i took a shot the market didn't want
it i gave up quickly
um i used to have an engineer
who worked for me who was absolutely
brilliant and
he would create great products um and he
would work an hour two hours a day and
then he would very blatantly sit around
watching qriket matches or playing uh
counter-strike which was this uh online
game uh while all the other people in
the office were just looking at him and
he just looked really lazy uh and people
complained to me about him all day long
but he added tons of value by creating
the right product the right way at the
right time yeah so he could get away
with it and he would have this pretense
of sitting around the water cooler and
talking uh or going to meetings he
didn't want to waste time on those
things he basically either enjoying
himself or he was working on what he
thought was effective and i think his
talent to some extent allowed him to get
away with it but
just given the the era that we live in
talent matters so much more than hard
work uh yeah and he would exemplify that
yes
and it's interesting because all the
books that have been coming out in
recent years from from outliers to
all the books related to talent being
secondary to hard work in the 10 000
hours and everything it's the exact
opposite message
that that hard work supersedes talent
and
i think that's a separate sort of
discussion but
but there is you know
there is a truth to the fact that
um
humans tend to do many things in order
to satisfy those who are watching them
and they also do tend to do many things
in order to satisfy
the idea of having tried
and romantically failed
failure
is also something that is considered
not only okay
but
almost lauded now you know
as i as i say these words i'm certain
that some in the audience are getting
ready to say that one must fail in order
to succeed and quite frankly i've never
looked at that as failure i i've when i
when i say failure i've always looked at
it personally as ultimate failure not
getting to where you want to go
ultimately everything besides that to me
i call experimentation i think
everything is in it everything is
experimentation there is no failure
along the way
yeah i agree i mean especially i think
the speed of iteration is what drives
learning so you know in gladwell and
others they say 10 000 hours of grinding
i think it's quite that simple if i do
the same thing for 10 000 hours
that's not going to be very effective if
in 10 000 hours i run a hundred
experiments that's great but it's not as
effective as if i ran a thousand
experiments or ten thousand experiments
so the speed of iteration matters
that said it's still not hard work alone
because i could play golf for ten
thousand hours and i would never be
tiger woods
tiger woods played golf for ten thousand
hours yes it was hard work but it was
also for the sheer love of it like he
enjoyed every you know he enjoyed most
of those days most of those times uh and
it was sort of in his nature and
character by some point to not look at
hitting the the you know golf links of
hard work he looked at that as the thing
that he most wanted to do that day
um so this idea of suffering and
sacrifice all this romantic and it
levels the playing field a little bit i
think it also misleads us
it misleads us into thinking that
everybody can be everyone
one interesting
hypothesis i heard is that in modern
society
one of the reasons we have more unhappy
people is because of the myth that
everyone can be everything
excuse me so yeah so if you think you
can be uh you know larry page or steve
jobs or jeff bezos
or mark zuckerberg but you didn't make
it it's because you didn't work hard
enough and then you feel lousy about
yourself whereas the reality is like
their talents uh intersected in the
right way at the right time and they put
in the hard work uh for the thing that
they were meant to create and your
talents are gonna intersect in a
completely different way uh in a
different place at a different time and
a lot of life is just searching for
uh
what it is that you're uniquely good at
and where and when to apply that thing
that's exactly right
the last line that you mentioned
absolutely i think is is the key um i
don't
you know
this sort of may sound um
sort of really
counter-intuitive
but
i don't think anybody fails because of
not working hard enough
i don't think that that creature exists
i think that
people fail because they didn't really
want it
i don't think that a sufficient degree
of desire exists in a given person
but
because he just didn't do
quote do enough work that he failed i
don't really buy that i think i would
say that if he didn't do the quote work
or do the leg work or do whatever needed
to be done
it's because the desire you got to look
more upstream i think the desire wasn't
there i don't think the desire is
bursting through you and you choose to
hold back that desire and not do it i
don't i don't i don't i don't think
that's the case
yeah i've always had a belief that
companies don't fail when they run out
of cash they fail when the founders and
team run out of energy
basically say okay we're done here
at some level you have to give up on
something and just because and it's
pragmatic there are other things that
you want to do more by that point
but if you have an unswerving desire to
do something then usually you'll get it
yeah although i think i think in this
modern age we tend to have too many
loosely scattered imitative desires
correct um there's that great old
chinese thing like man who chases two
rabbits catches none
so a lot of it is just about cultivating
your desire and being ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
you